[Music]
it's like playing by braille
you have supposed to play by feel
i've been with music since i was
practically born
i can't live without playing the violin
it's all about music that's relaxed or
music that's
intense that just kills you in a good
way
in this class i'm going to talk about
intonation you talk about vibrato
talk about colors posture different
styles of playing
make the bow work for you don't force
the boat to
jump the boat says i'm only jumping if
you leave me alone
be a musician it's almost like to be a
magician you don't want
the listener to realize what you're
doing
if you get all of that stuff you can
learn to play the violin
in two hours i'm just kidding
the old-fashioned master classes is when
the student plays
and the teacher says let me show you how
it goes that's not teaching that's
basically showing
i want whenever they do something to be
their own
when i'm playing if i don't feel
something in the music nothing is going
to happen
when you connect with the music that
connection will radiate
the audience
i'm going to bring some of my students
to sit in and to have a discussion
is there a difference between being
intense and being passionate
if you can feel my enthusiasm for music
the class has accomplished a lot to be
happy
forming great music and enjoy what
you're doing
what could be better i'm itzak pearlman
and this is my master class
[Music]
you